an evacuation flight leaving kabul
dropping chaff as it goes to protect
against incoming fire
the lucky ones they leave with their
lives but that's about
it the desperation of those trying to
get on one of these flights has been
hard to watch let alone witness
in the danger and chaos here one afghan
family
three children two grandparents in
wheelchairs
somehow managed to get through this on
tuesday prior to taliban really coming
to kabul i had received several threats
and as i said their father a lawyer
spoke to us from safety in qatar
still too fearful to be identified or
named
because his hope is to one day return
home
there are a lot of gun fires uh taliban
were fighting and they are trying to
spread people it's obviously not easy
for the kids to to see that they had
never seen it from that close this
distance that that someone would be
shooting with ak-47 some people
will call you one of the lucky ones yeah
how do you feel right now
i'm sure lucky isn't necessarily a word
that you would use
i couldn't complete my education without
bordering people money from people
but when i went back afghanistan i
started this practice by myself
and soon we were like like the best law
firm in the country
i had a lot of money in my account
i was helping any anyone who was asking
for help
but then all of a sudden buddha make
allah
it's not easy to quit i started building
from scratch
and i really don't agree with this that
that
okay you got out you gotta now do what
and the kind of life that i was used to
the kind of life that i provided for my
family i don't think if i would be able
to do that again
u.s flights have now resumed into qatar
after arrivals here became overwhelmed
that in turn added pressure to the chaos
in kabul where for eight hours u.s
flights didn't leave and troops on the
ground had to deal with the crisis
but it's politicians who've created this
mess
and in kabul where there's fear for the
future under taliban rule talks have
begun between their leaders and former
president hamid karzai
qatar has set the stage for this country
to be a key player in what happens next
doha is quite likely to be where talks
take place between countries wanting
dialogue with the taliban
and for now it's proving a critical
partner in the urgent evacuation of
refugees seeking safety we're expecting
thousands of evacuees to be brought here
but that's just a fraction of those
desperate to escape and international
governments have had since last february
to plan this when here in doha the trump
administration signed a deal with the
taliban to withdraw troops from
afghanistan but with little over a week
to go until that deadline we're watching
a humanitarian crisis unfold in this
region
in qatar these children giggle excited
by the camera but oblivious to what
they've escaped
a generation who've never known the
taliban
and a nation
anxious for what comes next
sally lockwood sky news doha